bonsoir desbriel folle mais merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
pedro sanchez obtenu l'aval du parlement
pour prolonger 15 jours l'état d'alerté
une quatrième fois jusqu'au 24 mai
prochain quelle a été la réaction des
espagnols la réélection des espagnols
s'y habituer au confinement
ça sera nous avons huit semaines deux de
plus ça fait dix principes les phases
devrait commencer vers laquelle
troisième ou quatrième phase et la fin
de juin mais pas tout le monde va
commencer avec la première phase qui
devrait commencer le lundi 11 et
seulement les baléares et les canaries
sont à disposition de commencer la phase
un séjour aujourd'hui et demain les
comités autonomes vont demander au
ministre de la santé que les experts
permettent de commencer et et
confinement par zone par zone sanitaire
et c'est à dire que pas tous le mot sera
on sera possible de faire cette phrase 1
par exemple barcelone ne pourra pas
entrer dans cette phase jusque dans
quinze jours sûrement marit tandis que
madrid
la présidente de magritte a demandé
entrer dans la phase 1 et ça a provoqué
une crise interne du gouvernement 2
de madrid la directrice de générale de
santé publique vient de démissionner
parce que magritte n'est pas en
condition d'entrer dans la phase 1 or
justement les régions les moins touchées
on les comprend par l'épidémie manifeste
un petit peu leur impatience si on
comprend bien face à la tutelle de
madrid est ce qu'on peut parler en
espagne d'un bras de fer entre les
régions et le gouvernement espagnol
il ya un bras de fer surtout avec le
gouvernement indépendantiste de la
catalogne avec le gouvernement des
semaines c'est vrai et surtout il y a un
bras de fer aussi avec la communauté de
madrid
la présidente du fn ou ce qui est pour
la pointe de lance qui parti populaire
contre le gouvernement socialiste de
badauds sentiers c'est à dire que ces
deux communes étaient autonomes sont
vraiment un côté de l'autre les plus
durs dans leurs réclamations sur le
confinement tandis que les basques ont
finalement fait un pacte avec le
gouvernement sur la cuc of governance
à partir de maintenant et la gestion du
de confinement alors vous êtes à
barcelone on le répète qui connaît cette
ville chaleureuse et conviviale connaît
le nombre de terrasses la culture
espagnole on imagine que c'est terrible
pour la ville catalane et pas que pour
l'espagne dans son ensemble de ne pas
pouvoir notamment ouvrir les cafés les
terrasses avec la proche de l'été est la
saison touristique quel est l'état
d'esprit on imagine beaucoup
d'inquiétude
l'inquiétude c'est bien sûr pour le
tourisme parce que on doit se rappeler
que le 13 % puis de l'espagne est due au
tourisme c'est à dire que
on va sortir de cette crise on sait pas
comment on va sortir de cette crise
sanitaire mais on est sûr que on va
avoir une crise économique très
importante et on il ya beaucoup de
doutes de comment on va affronter on a
vu des petits commerces c'est pas
évident que beaucoup de petits commerces
peu à rouen à partir de juin
parce que beaucoup de petits commerces
et de petites entreprises vont échouer
le directement c'est à dire que
l'économie espagnole comme l'europe et n
ont pas entrés dans une récession
profonde
on verra si l'union européenne entre
dans une logique plus fédérale et moi
le nationaliste c'est à dire ça veut
dire que les espagnols en attendent
beaucoup de la part de l'union
européenne justement pour se sortir de
ce mauvais pas économique
oui parce que en espagne on pense que
cette pagani sanitaire n'est pas une
mauvaise gestion économique c'est à dire
que c'est quelque chose qui est arrivé à
au monde entier c'est une vie russe
global et on arrête sensations ont la
perception que l'europe du nord
l'allemagne se vendait à essayer de à
nouveau faire que cette crise soit
vraiment comme la crise 2008
en logique économique seulement
économique et très peu solidaire c'est à
dire que l'europe devrait entrer dans
une logique que en fonction de ce que
face l'europe du nord l'europe du sud
peut commencer à penser que cette union
n'est pas très intéressante pour la pour
la population
pourquoi je dis ça parce que nous avons
repas jusqu'à maintenant des partis de
l'extrême droite comme box qui fait du
populisme très nationaliste comment
l'italie salvini et cédera c'est à dire
que les européens du nord de réponse y
est ils peuvent perdre l'europe du sud
s'il n'y a pas de logique solidaire est
il seulement d'une logique monétaire
merci gabriel colomé d'avoir été avec
mon direct sur arte france professeur de
sciences politiques à l'université
autonome de barcelone